[Musique]
ce côté à la fois humain et inhumain des
métiers durs des métiers d'hommes c'est
à boulogne le premier port de pêche
français que nous l'avons retrouvée mais
ici pour être compétitif dans le marché
commun tous et industrialiser mécanisée
et automatisés
du chalutage par l'arrière qui remplit
le bateau de poissons prélevés sur un
banc opéré aux ultrasons la conserverie
où la marée sans boîte à la chaîne la
civilisation de consommation anta
billy's par des prouesses techniques
un métier qui n'était jusque-là
qu'artisanale et hasardeuse la bonne
pêche n'est plus à faire de chance c'est
simplement une question d'équipement
quant au cours du poisson il est souvent
transmis par radio avant que le bâtonnet
regagner le port ce système est
paraît-il à l'avantagé du consommateur
[Musique]
et que devient la pêche artisanale dans
tout cela certes les pêcheurs
indépendant existe encore
nous en avons rencontré dans un étrange
port nommés au de recel quelque chose de
curieux dans les lycées audresselles il
ya des pêcheurs
il ya des bateaux il n'y a pas de porc
ou elle soit organisée avec des
tracteurs parce que maintenant on a la
facilité de remonter les bateaux avec
des tracteurs chariot et tous les
bateaux alors les pas tous en et remonte
avec des chariots tracteurs et en
armement même chez nous où ils remonter
chez vous vous étiez devant votre porte
sa posture comme une voiture alors une
voiture exactement le métier d'après
vous pour vos parents ou si vous vous
l'avez connu c'était plus difficile
avant à oui ça y est c'est l esclave ya
170 ans ouvrier s'est pas exagérer bay
abaissant pour changer parce que les
femmes les femmes et les hommes
travailler dans des connards non non
d'une femme chez eux
les envols au ca c enfin c'est un
progrès voyez c'est le progress à voler
à ouidah oui parce que les familles
avaient autant de mal que le baril
l'hiver ici le moment pas grand chose à
faire
alors c'est à manger tout ce qu'on a
gagné n'était leur banque pour part
toujours à trouver un résultat je vais
faire
de boer sur les bronchites et puis à
pâques au mois d'avril on le rappelle
mais si c'était à choisir ou préférer
travailler face à payet milan ça dépend
des moments
mais là j'étais embarqué sur votre crâne
la première noire et j'ai deniers cas
parmi eux d'anciens francs il marié
d'une semaine et les deux autres semaine
d'après j'en ai fait juste pour les
frérots alors c'est pas malheureux de
travailler jour et nuit sur le pont des
24 48 heures seront fermés y ait avec
attention parce que c'est pas toujours
calme plat il faut y aller pourriez vous
voir ce qui se passe alors forcément ici
on est un petit peu
après gmail était proche des bruits
embry call on vit vous êtes à la fois
marins et pêcheurs
voilà on est fier de le dire qu'on est
marin c'est pas la voir au ski ferment
ou n'avons pas rentrer dedans
[Musique]